hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode 5 video
we learned so much about Abraham's group
this is basically like a DC group
episode I definitely did not expect to
get the big reveal that we got at the
end of the episode which I'll totally
talked about during spoilers I know
everyone is still wondering about
Carroll - it looks like next week is
when we're gonna learn more about that
so I'll address that - at the end of the
video real quick reminder - new round of
the giveaway starts right now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video real
simple so careful for spoilers from the
episode if you're not cut up but here we
go starting with top five moments number
five the bus flips it totally sets they
only made it 15 miles from the church
before the bus took a dive our IP Church
bus I think the last reliable car they
had was probably the Dodge Charger at
the prison so many awesome things
revealed in this brief moment before
everything went to [ __ ]
first off Eugene is never going to cut
that hair even if he gets his face
punched off by Abraham Maggie's totally
worried about someone else it is not
Beth and we get the start of our Abraham
flashbacks I didn't expect to get such a
deep dive into his past but we kind of
learned why he's so crazy number 4
Abraham Eugene origin story so all the
flashbacks just tell the story of what
happened to Abraham before he met Eugene
it was a nice juxtaposition that at the
end of the episode he found out that the
thing that saved his life was a complete
lie he was getting ready to kill himself
so does it matter that Eugene lied to
him I think in the final moments
whenever he was just kneeling down on
the road he probably didn't care he is
just batshit crazy it seems like based
on the flashbacks that's what the show
was explaining that he was just so out
of his mind that his wife and children
were afraid of him whenever we saw him
outside later it looked like their
corpses it actually desiccated for a
while even though the time jump made it
seemed like it was a short amount of
time between him waking up and finding
them gone I don't think that he's gonna
die anytime soon so hopefully we'll get
some more explanation about his life
before the apocalypse I don't think that
his story once he met Eugene is quite as
interesting as what happened before the
apocalypse though the flashbacks kind of
make him seem like a terrible person or
at least a well-meaning person who
doesn't realize that he's being terrible
either way at the group totally needs to
crash a pharmacy and find him some meds
to balance out his role needs to be
slowed big time
number three rest stop at the bookstore
this is actually one of the more fun
parts of the episode mostly because of
pervert Eugene this is just the first
time that we've seen him getting caught
watching them have sex I would be
willing to bet that he's been doing this
the whole time they've been together as
a group which is a little bit scary but
kind of funny it was nice to finally get
some time with Abraham and Rosita we
didn't get too much time with them alone
come to find out she is way smarter than
he is somehow I'm not surprised though
Abraham does not seem like much of a
thinking man didn't you think it was odd
though that they were burning books to
build that fire and then later we see
Eugene reading HG Wells the book itself
was just a little foreshadowing you know
the shape of things to come just
sounding a little bit ominous about what
might happen in their near future but I
also like the idea that it's science
fiction like Eugene exists in this
fantasy world where he's like yes the
lie can continue I can keep this up
forever turns out not so much number two
Eugene confession number one I killed
the bus I was a little bit upset that
Tara didn't go crazier like she wants to
continue to keep it a secret I think
maybe because she feels at home with a
group like she's starting to feel
comfortable and she doesn't want that to
be destroyed she seems so much happier
in this episode too like she and Eugene
were just starting to bond especially
over the mullet although this kind of
made their friendship turn a bit of a
corner especially the funny but really
creepy moment where she caught him
watching Abraham and Rosita have sex I
loved that she had to stop him from
confessing about the pervert sex stuff I
just came to say thank you
Eugene has gotten really interesting
lately I mean it's just like he is
bursting at the seams trying to let go
of this secret of his like it just wants
to come out of him so bad like he just
wants to tell someone the truth they're
still really far away from Washington DC
- it's not like they were really close
and my number one WTF moment
Eugene reveals his big secret the cure
is total [ __ ] there might be a cure
out there but he certainly has no idea
what it is people who read the comics
already knew about this but I feel like
even if you didn't the writing was kind
on the wall like he was being very weird
definitely not someone that you should
put your trust in and now that Abraham
punched the [ __ ] out of him he might be
dead I like that they cut the episode at
that moment they're just gonna leave us
wondering whether or not he's
still alive and next week we're jumping
back to Carol and Daryl so we're gonna
throw a two weeks at least to find out
maybe three if we go back to Rick in the
group after Carol and Daryl
so yes Eugene lied there is no cure
everyone's pissed they've been going to
Washington DC for absolutely no reason
but that's not technically true they do
have a really good shot of surviving in
Washington DC just because it's so
fortified and there's such good
infrastructure so does it matter that he
lied I would say yes I mean it does
matter a little bit but he was able to
save Abraham's life without really
thinking about it and everyone will have
a much better chance of surviving once
they get to DC that's why I think
eventually once everyone gets over the
fact that he's a total dirtbag for lying
to them they will see that going to DC
is a good thing I think everyone's
mostly just gonna be upset about them
having to split the group up as well as
all the people that died along the way
trying to get him to DC let me know what
was your favorite moment and what do you
think they're gonna do now are they
gonna head back to Rick's group are they
gonna continue on to DC remember there
is like an ocean of walkers in front of
them I'll say that I think that they're
gonna continue on to DC they're just
gonna find a different route overall I
gave the episode an a-minus for giving
us the deep psychological dive into
Abraham this really was his episode even
though Eugene had the big reveal Michael
Cudlitz the actor that plays Abraham was
actually doing a Twitter Q&A before the
episode and doing a whole bunch of
interviews just explaining how damaged
Abraham is psychologically I mean he was
damaged in the flashbacks so think about
where he is now
that's what I love The Walking Dead so
much is that it tells such an emotional
story for these characters like it's not
all about the gore of just them just
killing a bunch of walkers like it's not
the spectacle it really gets into the
emotional collateral damage during an
interview Michael Cudlitz explained that
they left things a little bit more vague
about what happened to his family in the
flashbacks it's just a little bit more
graphic what ends up happening to them
before they die but the effect is still
the same on Abraham it just explains why
he is so crazy in the head and how he
uses Eugene's mission to get over it or
to at least to ignore it I think the
Abraham and present-day now is gonna be
just like Rick was after the mid-season
finale last year like just almost
catatonic like he's broken emotionally
and he's a little bit broken physically
- the difference is is that you just saw
it on Rick's face
it's just a little more plainly like his
face was literally smashed in but that's
pretty much what happened to Abraham
emotionally just in general though
Abraham my favorite performer of the
episode Rosita number two though she is
so smart I can't wait to see more scenes
with her just one upping other
characters I feel like that's just a
subtle wink to the fact that she's not
just a pretty face so like I said next
week some really exciting stuff to look
forward to lots of Carol lots of Daryl
so be sure to subscribe to get my video
it looks like what's gonna be happening
is is we're gonna rewind to before Carol
ended up in the hospital based on the
teaser footage it looks like they
definitely had a plan so part of her
being in there is on purpose
I'm also got my fingers crossed that
they're gonna explain who it is with
Daryl in the bushes which I think it's
Noah and just to address the issue of
Eugene being Dead or Alive
I think that he's still alive I think
the Abraham is gonna have to live with
him walking around alive for a little
while longer no idea when he'll actually
end up dying though but both he and
Michael Cudlitz were up to series
regulars this season if that means
anything on Walking Dead anymore I guess
they can be cut off at any time just
like normal I'll be posting a Q&A for
this tomorrow you can click here to get
it a lot of the annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here for my
episode 4 video thank you so much for
watching salt high five and I will see
you guys tomorrow